oder wer strain bevor ich die wohnung
phase einmal ganz kurz hier rein dann
fahre ich weg kommen wieder und dann
gehe ich hier wieder rein
ja das macht man ein ich will meine
guten ideen ok ich nehme alles zurück
das teil funktioniert also ich muss
sagen bist du auf jeden fall den video
wo ich viel respekt vor also ein
bisschen angst habe ich schon wundert
euch nicht über den tisch der ist vom
letzten video noch so dreckig irgendwie
geht das nicht ab scheiße was geht ab
von herzlich willkommen
das open schild ist unsere obwohl ich
merke wahrscheinlich sind das sehe ich
ja ja egal was gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
heute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
mir auch noch ja heute steht was ganz
besonders an ich hab es glaub ich schon
in zwei videos angekündigt und zwar geht
es heute um pfefferspray also wirklich
echtes pfefferspray ich mache zurzeit
wieder sehr viele auspackt videos von
irgendwelchen seiten wie wish es wird
allerdings in zukunft auch noch viel
krimskrams von anderen seiten geben
geben wir alle über installieren
geschickt habt also weitere video den
einfacheren slam 30 alex wie beim ich
habe ich eine extrem große bestellung
abgegeben und habe dort auch dann direkt
mal diese beiden thema space bestellt
weil er mir vorgeschlagen wurden ich
fand das sehr interessant ich muss auch
dazu sagen die waren beide kostenlos
also ich musste nur im versand bezahlen
er lag bei beiden bei zwei euro also
insgesamt vier euro für diese beiden
pfefferspray ich habe das mal mit so
etwas professionelleren von amazon
verglichen wo dann auch mehr details
darüber stehen weil bei diesem hier
stehe jetzt zum beispiel gar nix außer
halt dass sie dazu da sind um angreifer
abzuwehren also steht daher wirklich in
der beschreibung diese etwas
professionelleren dinger von amazon
kosten aber auch nur zwischen 7 und 30
euro oder so ich hatte eigentlich für
dafür so ein bisschen privat trotzdem
sind die natürlich deutlich günstiger
und wir schauen uns jetzt erst mal an
was ich denn da bestellt habe gegen euch
einfach mal meinen bestell verlauf kann
man hier glaube da muss ich nicht viel
zu sagen das sind bestimmt über 70
sachen gerne schon das erste produkt ihr
sehr direkt
einmal kostenlos pfefferspray und das
hat sogar ein ziemlich cooles design
entscheiden wird so herzchen drauf
herren und damen selbstverteidigung
pfefferspray selbstverteidigungs
werkzeug blablabla farben und grösse ja
warte mal ab so genau fünf milliliter
und zehn milliliter ich habe keine
ahnung was ich da gestellt habt
beschreibung durch das spray der
angreifer blind die atemwege husten der
körper fühlt sich unwohl wenn es
unangenehm kribbeln und schmerzen
blablabla also das muss ich hier direkt
mal sagen leute macht es nicht zu hause
nach vor allem wenn ihr noch
minderjährig sei das ist da nichts für
euch und mit sofas ray sollte man auch
keinen spaß
ich habe nämlich gehört dass wenn ich
hier in meiner wohnung einmal ganz kurz
sprayer dass ich eigentlich die nächste
stunde hier nicht sein kann ob das
wirklich so ist probleme später mal aus
also was will ich wirklich machen so
wenn schon denn schon
das hier war dann das zweite auch
kostenlos wobei ich eigentlich dieses
hier bekommen habe glaube ich ja genau
also irgend eines davon größen ich habe
keine ahnung welche größe nicht
dargestellt habe ich denke aber mal das
ist maximal zehn milliliter sind weil
diese bei amazon lagen sogar 30 bis 50
milliliter und sonst wird das mit keinen
sinn machen warum das so günstig hier
vielleicht noch kurzen rezensionen kam
früher als gedacht die super aus ob es
funktioniert weiß ich nicht hatte noch
kein grund dazu
ja gut es ist sehr handlich und schön
dann würde ich sagen schauen uns mal
kurz an die sind schon auf weil ich habe
in diesem video zehn kostenlose risch
produkte aus versehen aus gepackt weil
wie will man die von anderen sachen
unterscheiden die sehen alle gleich aus
und sind alle gleich klein und alle
gleich eingepackt das hier ist das erste
ich glaube da ist wirklich nicht so viel
drin ich würde es mal auf zehn
milliliter schätzen kann ich nicht genau
sagen und das hier ist das zweite mal
eigentlich sind die vom design her
komplett identisch also beide mit herzen
drauf warum auch immer vielleicht damit
der angreifer denkt okay das ist ein
lippenstift und dann machst du so passen
wir auf ihr zack und nun ja es ist
wahrscheinlich die erklärung dafür ist
es als lippenstift getan also schon mal
sagen hier sind fünf milliliter drinnen
hier sind zehn milliliter drin
wahrscheinlich komplett das gleiche
pfefferspray ich will es gar nicht weine
drumrum lara ihr wollt ihr wissen ob es
funktioniert und dafür
haben wir jetzt erst mal in den wald
weil ich würde erstmal gerne im wald
testen bevor ich irgendwie die wohnung
komplett oder wir sprechen bevor ich die
bohrphase einmal ganz kurz die reihe
dann fahre ich weg kommen wieder und
dann gehe ich hier wieder rein
ja das mache ich mit meinem guten ideen
nein bedeute dann brauchen mal los ich
habe ihm ein stativ dabei damit ihr das
auch vernünftig sehen könnt und ja wir
freuen uns wie gesagt in den wald weil
ich niemanden gefährden möchte und sonst
was aber ich hab' solcher grad schon
versprochen
ich spreche jetzt einmal kurz in die
wohnung nachdem ich sie verlassen habe
und dann kommen wir gleich wieder und
dann bin ich mal gespannt ob man das
meer weil ich glaube ich unterschätzt
ist ein bisschen deswegen weiß ich bin
echt ein bisschen nervös presse 1 okay
leute ich bin chronischen war so
gespannt ob ich das gleich merken werde
wenn ich zurückkomme oder nicht naja
werden sie sich aber an die sie absolut
keine ahnung haben was du was auslösen
kann ich habe eben ein cooles video
gefunden wo das jemand direkt in seinem
gesicht ausprobiert und das ist echt
ganz schön heftig aus ich zeige dass mal
kurz kurzer ausschnitt viel spaß dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder
er ist über 50 minuten her ist trend
immer noch genau ich weiß nicht ob das
sehen kann
aber sie fühlt sich völlig roth an so
leute also herzlich willkommen ich bin
jetzt hier im wald das bisschen blöd
dringlich aber ist egal was wir machen
jetzt den test wie gesagt ich kann ja
niemanden gefährden oder so die stelle
die kamera jetzt einfach mal 3 meter
oder zwei meter von mir weg und
ansprechen eure richtung der wind kommt
ganz leicht von da deswegen soll das gar
kein problem sein okay wir starten mit
dem kleinen das habe ich ja gerade auch
schon meine wohnung ist rage mal gucken
wie es da gleich riecht 3 2 1
[Musik]
ok ich muss sagen ich gar nichts warte
mal ich hatte irgendwie schon gedacht
dass ein bisschen weiters break
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen habe ich mir ein
bisschen spektakulärer vorgestellt jetzt
probieren wir mal dass größere das
sollte auch weiter strain ich geh mal
gar nicht so weit weg
ok 3 2 1 der wind kommt ja doch von da
ich trottel warten
wenn ich jetzt blöd also ich richter dix
und mir passiert ja auch nichts weiter
gemacht wo es okay jetzt ist mir das
passiert so krass war das quartier
direkt in die nase alter krass okay ich
nehme alles zurück das funktioniert
jetzt hat sich dahinter mich irgendwo
eine frau gesetzt ich habe mitgekriegt
hat jetzt nicht ab ein kleines rad krank
in der nase sieht man dass man den augen
oder in der nase das habe ich jetzt
leicht unterschätzt wir fahren erst mal
zurück ich muss ein bisschen hier mein
gesicht war schon immer so hey hey leute
ich habe das so unterschätzende ich
glaube das ist ganz gut drauf ich war
nur heimat ganz leicht in dieser wolke
und meine nase brennt so krassen ich
habe ja auch kein wasser dabei und das
wurde es gerade von sekunde zu sekunde
immer schlimmer jetzt gehts kraft wieder
eigentlich ich glaube wenn man das
irgendwem so richtig ins gesicht springt
der ist auf jeden fall ko für die
nächsten stunden ich will mir gar nicht
vorstellen wie das in den augen brennt
wenn man das so richtig in die augen
kriegt wir fahren jetzt zurück in die
wohnung und dann bin ich mal gespannt ob
meine wohnung nach betretbar ist weil
ich habe in vielen kommentaren gelesen
wenn ich davon 1 bringen die war habe
ich auch schon gesagt wenn ich damit
einmal in der wohnung spray kann ich
komplett ich kann es euch hier sehr
gerne ein wenn die ganze etage
evakuieren da bin ich mal gespannt leute
das ding ist irgendwie das wird
überhaupt nicht besser also meine nase
brennt noch so krass und davon auch
sagen muss ich hab vorher so also ich
könnte die ganze zeit wussten das ist
jetzt erstmal vorgegeben davon die
nachfrage jetzt muss ich wussten aber
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was passieren
wird ich werde jetzt meine wohnung
wieder betreten
vielleicht gespannt
[Musik]
schild am ort im alter das echt heftig
simuliert das jetzt auch nicht oder so
aber in dieser luft man hat ich habe
schnell man auch die lüftung an machen
mir
leute ohne spaß in meinem zimmer ist
katastrophe ich kann da nicht reingehen
immer wenn ich das betreten muss ich so
dermaßen anfang zu husten weil ich
glaube es ist alles da hinten
reingezogen
ich gehe auf den ball kommen hier drin
halte ich täglich aus
das fühlt sich die ganze zunächst so an
als wenn die nase läuft aber sie läuft
nicht und dann brennt noch und die muss
ok so weiter wir haben jetzt
mittlerweile 14 uhr
ich habe das ganze um kurz vor zwölf
getestet also vor zwei stunden hab das
video gerade schon halbwegs fertig
geschnitten nehmen wir jetzt noch das
ende auch weil ich auch sagen kann so
meine nase geht zu weit ich habe gar
keine beschwerden mehr
ich glaube aber dass ich auch wirklich
nur nicht ganz ganz kleine menge
abbekommen habe ist er das auch auf den
aufnahmen so ich bin zwar immer
hinterher gerannt also hinter dieser
pfeffer wolke aber so wirklich getroffen
habe ich dir nur beim letzten mal
ich habe irgendwie nicht so richtig
wahrgenommen weil dies ja so immer
relativ schnell weggezogen und würden
bloßen auge war das nicht so leicht zu
erkennen von der position her ich weiß
ja wissen steht trotzdem kann ich hier
zu sagen punkt sieht auf jeden fall
optimal also kassel wirkung
das einzige was nicht so cool ist ist
die distanz die man damit überbrücken
kann also ich denke mal dass es maximal
50 zentimeter auf diese
professionelleren straits die jenaer
bestimmt irgendwie zwischen fünf und
zehn meter weit ich bin jetzt auf jeden
fall meine erfahrungen weiter und habe
mal führers früher eingeatmet wirklich
interessant ich empfehle euch trotzdem
ich das mal auszuprobieren vor allem
nicht wenn ihr unter 18 seid eigentlich
ist das nur zur abwehr von wilden tieren
gedacht in deutschland sonst hochgradig
illegal
das war's mit dem video wollen wir einen
32 alex wie abonniert den kanal
aktiviert die glocke und schreibt mir
vor allem weitere video ideen die ihr
gerne haben würde in die kommentare oder
bei instagram wir sehen uns morgen
wieder mainz nur jeden tag neues video
hat
ich freue mich